What would you recommend for a stomach virus with nausea, headache,
many loopholes, very weak, very low energy?
Well, you know, how would you know what's a virus?
Well, if you did a CBC with a differential,
if you're thinking you have a virus or some sort of infection,
things that would give you clues.
You'd have an elevated white blood cell comp,
which may still be within normal lab range,
but is outside of functional range.
Remember, that's probably the biggest discrepancy
of any blood value is the white blood cell count.
Lab range of white blood cell count could be 4.0 to,
you know, upward to 12.
They still consider normal,
whereas a functional white blood cell count is maybe 4.5
to upwards to maximum of seven,
anything over that would be considered,
you probably have an infection.
So let's say you have a 8.5 white blood cell count,
then you look at the differential.
If neutrophils are elevated over lymphocytes,
then you most likely have a bacterial infection.
If lymphocytes are elevated over neutrophils,
then you most likely have a virus.
So that's how you do to a cursory clue of,
do I have a virus or do I have a bacterial infection?
Because you would treat it a little differently.
Now, either one you would use, you know,
some, you know, this pretty much is similar neutrosuticals.
Anything that's going to be an immune system is,
a immune booster is going to help.
But if it's a bacterial infection,
you know, you might hit it a little bit harder on garlic and oregano.
And then you depended on what you think,
what you think it could be like H. Pylora.
You might hit it with burberry and things like that as well.
Definitely, you want to call down the dot.
And if your stools are loose,
decrease magnesium, decrease something that would make it looser,
and add some fiber to see if that can help bind things up.
So those are things that you want to think of.
Get a proper diagnosis whether it's a bacterial infection
or it's a virus.
And then either way from a neutrosutical standpoint,
you're going to use an immune stimulant to help kill it.